es war das menschheitsverbrechen
schlechthin eine humanitäre katastrophe
ohne beispiel über 65 millionen tote
darunter mehr zivilisten als soldaten
mindestens 24 millionen vertriebene und
entwurzelte in ganz europa und rechnete
ohne zahl
wir reden vom zweiten weltkrieg der vor
genau 70 jahren zu ende gehen genauer
gesagt vor 70 jahren gingen die
kampfhandlungen zu ende
der krieg lebt fort in der erinnerung
auch bei den nachgeborenen kriegs enkel
wie wir den krieg bis heute spüren liebe
zuschauer das thema der phoenix runde
willkommen bei uns meine gäste hier im
studio jens ohr buck aus schweden sind
generalsekretär der olof palme
stiftungen stockholm
sie haben ein buch geschrieben mit dem
titel schatten auf meiner seele ein
kriegs enkel entdeckte geschichte seiner
familie erzählt die geschichte ihrer
deutschen mutter die aus pommern stammte
und dort in pommern 1945 den einmarsch
der roten armee erlebt hat katrin
himmler ist bei uns
politikwissenschaftlerin sie sind die
großnichte des reichsführers ss heinrich
himmler der für die schlimmsten
verbrechen des nazi-regimes
hauptverantwortlich war
sie haben auch ein buch geschrieben mit
dem titel die brüder himmler eine
deutsche familiengeschichte
darin versuchen sie die verstrickungen
ihrer familie in die ns-zeit und den
krieg aufzuarbeiten die brüder himmler
bezieht sich auf die beiden brüder von
heinrich himmler der jüngere von beiden
ernst ihm dabei ihr großvater gewesen
randi crott ist bei uns journalisten
autoren auch sie haben in sich in einem
buch über ihre familiengeschichte
geäußert titel erzähle es niemanden die
liebesgeschichte meiner eltern hinter
diesem buch verbirgt sich tatsächlich
eine liebesgeschichte ihr vater war
wehrmachtsoldaten und halbjude was er
erfolgreich verbergen konnte
es hat ihn auch geschützt und eigentlich
gerettet denn solange in der wehrmacht
waren dass niemand wusste war er von
verfolgung verschont er war in norwegen
stationiert ihre mutter ein norwegisches
mädchen die dort kennengelernt ist nach
dem krieg nach deutschland gekommen
sie haben dann hier geheiratet und
schließlich sabine bode die auf die
spätfolgen von ns zeit und krieg in
vielfältiger form aufmerksam gemacht hat
sie haben journalistisch darüber
gearbeitet bücher veröffentlicht die
titel die vergessene generation kriegs
enkel und nachkriegs kinder die bei
ihrer erscheinung großes aufsehen erregt
haben
der titel unserer sendung lautet ja wie
dir den krieg ist heute spüren
wie spüren wir denn den krieg bis heute
frau budde zum beispiel darin dass wir
obwohl es 70 jahre vergangen sind also
jedes mal wenn man nachts nicht schlafen
kann und im fernsehen selbst ungefähr 5
beiträge zum thema dieses krieges sieht
frau grott wie spüren wir den krieg bis
heute wie spüren sie den krieg bis heute
echte gerade heute genau in diesen
minuten an diesen krieg vor allen dingen
an das kriegsende denn genau jetzt vor
70 jahren
abends nach 22 uhr hat sich die deutsche
wehrmacht in norwegen ergeben nachdem
das morgens ja schon in rousses passiert
war mit der bedingungslosen kapitulation
und da denke ich natürlich gerade heute
daran dass ja für die norweger eine
schwierige eine furchtbare fünfjährige
besatzungszeit zu ende gegangen ist vor
70 jahren
und ich habe das natürlich sehr gespürt
in der zeit in der ich an meinem buch
gearbeitet habe das buch was ich mit
meiner mutter zusammen geschrieben habe
was dieser krieg bedeutet hat und wie es
auch mich in meinem leben tangiert wie
spüren sie den krieg bis heute oder wie
spüren wir insgesamt den kriegen sollte
er für mich weiß erstmal ein
körperliches gefiel das ist ich etwas in
meiner eigenen körper hat ich wusste das
nicht und ich möchte damit so in einem
bewusstsein gefühle
arbeiten und deshalb musste ich diese
geschichte befinden und auch wörter auf
die geschichte sonst pur man ihn auch in
schweden über es die schwedische
verhältnisse in das krieg und sozialität
und so was aber für mich war es erstmal
einen körperlich gefehlt
lediglich so bewusst sein wie sich die
das körperliche gefühl angefühlt hat das
da werden dann auch gleich darüber reden
es geht ja um das schicksal ihrer mutter
von dem sie sich dann auch persönlich
betroffen gefühlt haben von energie
spüren wir heute den krieg noch zum
einen denke ich was frau wurde eben
gesagt hat würde ich dem auch zustimmen
dass wir bis heute fast rund um die uhr
aber besonders nachts endlos viele
sendungen zu dem thema haben es ist
etwas was immer noch nicht verarbeitet
ist wirklich und wo es immer wieder neue
forschung zugibt aber ich glaube was
noch viel wichtiger ist was wir erst
allmählich beginnen zu erkennen was ja
auch die bücher von frau bode zeigen und
der große anklang den sie finden dass
wir das in den familien noch lange nicht
verarbeitet haben sondern dass da ganz
vieles immer noch am schwelen ist und
gerade erst durch die nachfolgenden
generationen langsam mehr aufgearbeitet
wird dann gehen sie uns einige
ratschläge verbote sie haben ausführlich
über dieses thema gearbeitet
es gibt ja kaum jemanden der davon nicht
betroffen ist konfrontiert ist über das
schweigen oder auch über das reden in
der familie wie das in meiner war wir
haben sehr früh darüber gesprochen aber
es wird eben auch viel geschwiegen
was ist ihnen wenn sie das vielleicht
ganz kurz schildern was in ist ihnen
dabei ihre arbeit alles begegnet was sie
die wichtigsten erfahrungen die sie da
gemacht haben
in bezug auf die kriegs enkel ja mich
hat überrascht dass verunsicherte
lebensgefühl
obwohl die eigene biografie das nicht
hergibt was immer wiederholt wurde ich
stehe mit einem fuß auf dem gas und mit
anderen auf der bremse ich komme in
meinem eigenen leben nicht an ich bin
blockiert und was auch noch wichtig war
und was mich völlig überrascht das hat
mich am meisten überrascht
das waren damals menschen ich habe ich
habe die gespräche 2007 2008 geführt die
waren nicht abgenabelt das waren
menschen
- 40 jahre und das konnte ich mir auch
lange nicht erklären und es war wirklich
eine große auffälligkeit in diesen
jahrgängen der 1960 er und 1970 er jahre
was frau wurde jetzt gesagt hat haben
sie das an ihrem eigenen erleben
nachvollziehen können beweisen können
oder vielleicht habe ich es auch ganz
anders erlebt vorkommt ich hab
eigentlich anders erlebt ich habe erst
sehr spät erfahren was meine familie
insbesondere mit dem krieg zu tun haben
abgesehen davon dass ich natürlich immer
wusste dass dieses eine deutsch
norwegische liebesgeschichte war die
ohne krieg ja so gar nicht möglich
gewesen wäre
ansonst immer gesagt ohne entwickler
gleich gar nicht auf der welt kenner und
dass das ist ein komisches gefühl zu
denken ohne oder väter wäre ich gar
nicht da das ist ein gefühl da fehlt mir
auch wortführer man so ein gefühl
bezeichnen kann
aber ich habe in meiner kindheit und
meiner jugend eigentlich nicht so
gespürt dass da irgendwas nicht stimmt
und das weshalb ich ja denn das buch
geschrieben habe nämlich um zu begreifen
weshalb mein vater nicht geredet hat
über seine jüdische herkunft ich habe im
nachhinein nicht nur ihn verstanden
sondern muss sagen ich war ihm auch ein
bisschen dankbar
also dadurch hatte ich eine relativ
unbeschwerte kindheit und jugend und
musste nicht dieses trauma wenn er
darüber erzählt hätte so nachvollziehen
als kind als jugendliche ich habe dann
als erwachsene diesen schritt machen
müssen nachdem ich erst mit 18 erfahren
habe dass mein vater ein jüdischer
abstammung hat und meine oma ideen
gewesen ist meine oma in einem
konzentrationslager war und meine
großtante in einem konzentrationslager
ermordet worden ist
wie haben sie das erlebt haben
verbotes gesagt diese will sich das in
dieser generation ausgewirkt haben sie
sich da auch wieder erkannt oder gibt es
auch bei ihnen eine individuelle
reaktion
ja und nein also teilweise erkenne ich
mich darin schon wieder weil ich
natürlich auch geprägt bin als
angehörige der dritte dritten generation
von diesen von diesen auswirkungen die
das die das hat über so viele jahre
beziehungsweise die tatsache dass auch
meine eltern kriegskinder gewesen sind
hat sich natürlich auch sicherlich auf
meine erziehung ausgewirkt auf der
anderen seite gehören wir natürlich zu
einer so genannten täter familie und da
sieht es noch mal anders aus also bei
uns ging es nicht so sehr um die frage
der trauerverarbeitung des krieges der
kriegserlebnisse der schrecklichen
sondern bei uns stand immer im
vordergrund
diese täter geschichte weil wir von
anfang an immer gewusst haben als kinder
dass wir mit heinrich himmler verwandt
sind und dass da etwas sehr belastendes
sehr schweres in unserer
familiengeschichte ist das wurde auch
nie verheimlicht das war immer thema von
anfang an und gab es einen sehr offenen
umgang mit aber insofern war der
schwerpunkt natürlich bei uns ein
anderer diese körperliche gefühl von dem
sie da gerade gesprochen haben dass wenn
ich das richtig verstanden hab das kam
aber eigentlich bevor ihre mutter zum
ersten mal mit ihnen darüber gesprochen
hat das heißt es ist eigentlich im
unbewussten erst mal abgelaufen und
bewusst ohne wörter habe ich hatte ein
gefühl dass meine mutter so viel von
dieser geschichte beeinflusst war
und jetzt hätte ich auch diese
geschichte in mein körper aber ich hätte
keine wörter und es ist ganz schwer über
diese dinge so werden für mich deutsche
werden aber das war auch viele kraft um
diese schwarze loch herum so gern mehr
und mehr kraft haben wir benutzt um
diese dinge nicht zu sprechen und nicht
mit die geschichte nicht mit die eltern
nicht mit die nachbarn um sohn und dann
möchte ich glaube dass vielleicht
mussten wir bisschen licht daran haben
so dass wir auch in das loch reingehen
kann
und wenn wir das gemacht hat ist dann
ist das gefühl bis im wasser obwohl
jetzt haben sie ja gehört jeder hat sein
individuelles schicksal seine eigene
erfahrung gehabt es gibt nicht den
tricks enkel oder das kriegskind haben
die trotzdem diese generationen
untereinander gemeinsamkeiten haben sie
dir entdecken können egal welches
schicksal man hat obmann vertrieb da war
und man ausgebombt wurde oder ob die
familie relativ ungeschoren aus dem
krieg davon kann also bei den
kriegskindern kann man sagen die größte
gemeinsamkeit ist dass sie der meinung
waren sie hätten eigentlich nichts
schlimmes erlebt sie sagten immer das
werden wir waren doch kinder das war für
uns normal und zu sind kinder wenn
kinder etwas erfahren was ringsum
genauso ist das kann die schlimmste
katastrophe sein wenn sie keine
vergleichsmöglichkeiten haben bleibt das
normal und sie betäuben sich selbst um
das zu ertragen und diese betäubung kann
ein leben lang anhalten und auch die
vorstellung dass es normales kann ein
leben lang anhalten wenn es nie von
außen angesprochen wird das genau ist
bei den kriegskindern passiert und erst
jetzt im alter fällt den meisten auf ja
und sie bekriegen die angemessenen
gefühle dazu und sie waren eben in
gewisser weise zitiert wir das hat ihm
geholfen das hat ihn zu einem
erfolgreichen leben geholfen
bei den kriegs enkeln wiederum würde ich
mal sagen ist dass angekommen was die
eltern von sich fernhalten können
nämlich die ängste natürlich haben
kriegskinder am alle menschen ängste
wenn sie schlimme erfahrungen
ausgeliefert sind aber ich sage ja der
war diese betäubung und nun ist das eben
leider so dass was man in jeder
psychologischen praxis die ängste die
verdrängt werden landen mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit bei den kindern und
die kinder obwohl sie behütet aufwachsen
obwohl sie friedens kinder sind obwohl
die eltern alles tun damit ihre kinder
sich wohlfühlen spüren das und sie
kriegen von den eltern keine resonanz
sein
wieso hast du angst du bist sicher und
das ist ein schönes haus und eine nette
familie und sie eltern reagieren darauf
nicht die eltern verstehen ihre kinder
nicht das heißt um es mal klar zu machen
krieg hört eben nicht auf wenn die
waffen schweigen bei krieg beschädigt
nachhaltig die beziehung und die
beziehungsfähigkeit eltern können nicht
in dem maß unbefangen auf die nöte und
sorgen und ängste von kindern eingehen
weil sich unbewusst etwas ganz viel
anderem vergleich nämlich das was sie
erlebt haben und dann schauen sie sich
so ein kind an und sagen ja ja das wird
schon vorbei gehen das ist eine phase
sie können das nicht wirklich ernst
nehmen und sie können nicht trösten
diese traumatische erfahrung gilt er für
alle traumatischen erfahrungen nicht
mehr für den für den krieg also das wird
ja quasi weitergegeben oder weiter
vererbt wie ein genetischer code wie
wirkt sich das aus diese in der nächsten
generation und diese unverarbeitete
diese verdrängte vergangenheit also ich
glaube dass es wirklich am stärksten ist
es eine lebens- blockade also irgendwo
ist die lebensenergie nicht so wie sie
sein sollte denn die haben ja in der tat
bessere bedingungen als ihre eltern
haben die eltern die kriegskinder sind
aber haben viel mehr energie nämlich
über lebensenergie als ihre eigenen
kinder und sie erleben also zu mir reden
die ja auf mehr
die verstehen das ja meistens nicht und
sie sagen was haben die denn für ängste
haben doch nichts schlimmes erlebt ich
müsste ängste haben aber ich hab sie
nicht ihr und es ist eben so dass die
also wenn man aufwächst und hat
keinerlei vertrauen ins leben bekommen
gleichzeitig lebt man in der besten
aller welten wissen was man dann denkt
dann denkt man man spinnt man ist
verrückt ja man erzählt dass auch
niemand anders weil man denkt keiner
versteht ein
und das kann dann eben in der mitte des
lebens
offenbar werden meistens nicht weil man
einfach auf die suche geht weil niemand
beschäftigt sie freiwillig gerne mit so
einer furchtbaren zeit schon gar nicht
in der eigenen familie das passiert dann
in einer lebenskrise das ist dann zeit
sich mit den eigenen wurzeln zu
beschäftigen gut wie das konkret
aussieht einer der gäste hat das ja auch
beschrieben sein buch nämlich in forbach
ich bin das vielleicht ganz kurz
zitieren was sie da geschrieben haben
wie ihn das passiert ist in einem
sommerurlaub das unangenehme gefühl
schreiben sie dass ich beim aufwachen
empfand gingen eine art panik über es
war als viele ich in einen abgrund und
ich wusste nicht wie weit ich noch
fallen würde als würden sich ständig
weitere schichten öffnen ins bodenlose
ich würde in etwas hineingezogen womit
ich nicht umgehen konnte ich konnte es
nicht in worte fassen
aber es war etwas in meiner mutter das
jetzt in mir war das ist das was die
gemeinde ja dass das mein hase nennen
das kann man in projekte nennt man das
glaube ich in der psychoanalyse man es
geht etwas in die zweite generation über
und es ist noch mal bedrohlich weil man
kann es ja nicht verorten man weiß nicht
was es ist
aber sie haben gemerkt es kommt kann der
mutter und das für mich gab es auch drei
ursachen weil ich das buch nicht
geschrieben hat geschichte geschrieben
haben
erst das ist sehr schwer über
vergewaltigung zu sprechen
sie reden als von den erfahrungen
erlebnissen ihrer mutter ja es ist
schwer für ein sohn
ihr mutter zu fragen wie viele mal was
du verwaltung überlegt
es war auch schwer weil es ein
unangefochtene verbund zwischen mein
vater und meine mutter dass man nicht
über das spricht und dann war es auch
ein verbund diese geschichte war auch
somit mit schuld verbunden also auch von
ihrer mutter ihrer schuld im jahr ab
obwohl sie ihre opfer gewesen ja obwohl
obwohl sie das fest und so ist es ja
auch heute wenn ein wenn eine frau
vergewaltigt ist dann ist die erste was
sie auch denkt ist wie soll ich es
machen so dass niemand weiß was passiert
ist obwohl obwohl sie das offen ist und
das ist schade dass es so ist
ich habe viel damit auch gearbeitet dass
ich minister für gleichstellung in
schweden war und das ist das ist nicht
gut aber das gab dann auf ursachen weil
ich das damit arbeiten möchte und mein
vater war gestorben und meine mutter hat
ein gutes leben in schweden aber sowieso
das war etwas das nicht für sie gut war
und dann habe ich anfang ich habe
angefangen zu fragen und es ist so
glaube ich dass man kann ich sagen dass
das mit ein traum also man fragen soll
man nicht fragen soll man erzählen so
gar nicht erzählen alle hat seine eigene
werk dazu aber wenn man gefragt hat dann
muss man warten und ich hab zu zehn
jahre gewartet
was ich jetzt gerade vorgelesen hat
dieses erlebnis in einem sommerhaus
es war so eine art seelische attacke die
sie irgendwie bis ich gespürt was in
meiner mutter war war plötzlich auch in
mir wie ist es ihnen gelungen ihre
mutter zum reden zu bringen dieses
schweigen zu brechen
das war ganz schwer das also ich gesagt
dass es schwer für einen sohn zu fragen
über die vergewaltigung aber ich hab
halt auch ein freund einfach von estland
die hat so ein bisschen mit meiner
mutter gefährdet und auf ein café das
genommen und dann bin ich zusammen mit
meiner mutter
um diese kasse mit diese kassette und
ich habe alle meine kraft für diese play
herunter und dann haben wir zusammen sie
haben dieses gespräch aufgenommen auf
kassette und das war ihre mutter carmen
1949 nach schweden als deutsches mädchen
dann in den westen geflüchtet 945 149
kam sie nach später hat ihren späteren
mann einen schweden kennen gelernt ihren
vater ich glaube erst nach dem tod ihres
vaters hat sie sich ja auch geöffnet und
hat darüber gesprochen wollte siegen da
schonen was war der grund dass sie
darüber nicht offen geredet hat ich
glaube dass das war so ein austausch
oder eine zwischen schuld und leiten
wenn sie nicht über das leitern hoch
sprach dann können sie das schult
bisschen ausgleichen so ist glaube ich
so ein bisschen so aber dann wie ich bin
endlich das wir haben eine tv programm
über die vergewaltigung in kalk
angesehen und dann hat sie gesagt ich
weiß wie das ist
und dann haben es gibt ein bisschen mehr
auf mich das heißt das was damals im
kosovo krieg oder im jugoslawien krieg
passiert es war sozusagen der
unmittelbare anlass zu sagen ich kenne
das ja selbst als solche kaum ein wort
da ein wort da aber nicht so viel und
dann dann möchte ich nicht diese
geschichte in meinem körper also
wahrlich eine initialzündung dann für
ihre mutter als ihre mutter mit ihnen
dann
wochen hat als sie das nach und nach
erzählt hat was sie danach eine andere
über ihre mutter danach irgendwie hat
sie sich danach anders verhalten haben
sie sie danach anders gesehen hat sie
sich erleichtert gefühlt darüber
gejammert haben sie dass das war ein
schwerer prozess und therapeut für ein
sohn zu ihre mutter ist vielleicht nicht
eintracht dass ich gebe aber werden wir
das buch geschrieben haben und sie auch
so erwachsene menschen über diese
geschichte erzählen könnte dann war sie
erleichtert
sie könnte bis hin zu meine kinder
erzählen aber das war nur mehr spannung
über dieser krieg und sie möchten wissen
wie es war mit die russen und die
soldaten und so
und das kann es ja wie sie können nicht
später als dreizehnter märz 1945 zahlen
erzählen dann weiß schluss das heißt bis
zu dem tag an dem mir das widerfahren
ist die vergewaltigung hat sie auch im
leben
danach war das leben quasi wie eine
black box ein schwarzes loch das sie
verdrängt hatte wo immer sie haben ja
ein furchtbares erbe in ihrer familie
heinrich himmler eine der schlimmsten
kriegsverbrecher halt so wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe so als das
schwarze schaf in der familie auf denen
man alles schlechte alles negative alle
schuld projizieren konnte dass ich die
anderen da in der familie zum teil auch
drunter weggeduckt haben
ihr vater hat dann so sein vater ernst
hinter der bruder von heinrich himmler
war ja auch verstrickte hat ja auch
profitiert von der ns zeit hat sich
bereichern können hat angeblich sogar
denunziert einen jüdischen mitarbeiter
im rax rundfunk denunziert ihr vater hat
dann zu ihnen gesagt sie sollen sich
doch bitte um die familiengeschichte
kümmern recherchieren was da war
warum hat er das eigentlich von ihnen
den auftrag gegeben dass ich die
familiengeschichte recherchieren sollte
sondern er hat mir den anstoß gegeben in
dem er mich gefragt hat
vor vielen jahren ob ich mal im
bundesarchiv nachschauen könnte ob es
über seinen vater eigentlich eine akte
gäbe sprich ob er in der partei gewesen
sei möglicherweise auch in der ss weil
mein vater das schon sehr lange vermutet
hatte dass es so sein könne
aber irgendwie eine bestätigung dafür
hatte er hat selber darüber nichts von
seiner mutter erfahren können die hat
komplett geschwiegen darüber und sein
vater war einfach nicht prominent genug
in der nazi hierarchie als dass es so
einfach gewesen wäre etwas selbst über
ihn herauszufinden
das war der anstoß den er mir gegeben
hat weil er selbst keineswegs sein vater
entlastet hat indem er heinrich himmler
die ganze schuld zugeschoben hat sondern
er hat immer vermutet oder befürchtet
dass das auch der eigene vater
wesentlich mehr verstrickt wird
gleichzeitigkeit befürchtet dass
möglicherweise da dinge raus kommen die
wiederum die familie belasten und
vielleicht lang lotionen zu lassen
die angst war sehr groß was da raus
kommen könnte und letztlich glaube ich
eher durch meine recherchen die damit
eigentlich erst angestoßen wurde ich bin
ich bin neugierig geworden und habe
immer weiter gegraben und versucht immer
mehr herauszufinden wo ich festgestellt
habe dass nicht das bis dahin sehr wenig
interessiert hatte was genau was
speziell diesen eigenen großvater betraf
weil er für mich immer so unter dem
techniker lief das war so der ingenieur
der techniker und das hat mich
thematisch so wenig interessiert und ich
war immer überzeugt dass er gar nicht so
viel damit hätte zu tun haben können und
deswegen war es nicht so ein thema für
mich
das hat in ihrer in ihren weiteren
verwandtenkreis auch zu sehr
unterschiedlichen reaktionen geführt ich
glaube auch zu zerwürfnissen
wie hat man da reagiert das war sehr
unterschiedlich also jeder geht ja
sowieso mit dieser geschichte sehr
anders um und insgesamt würde ich sagen
dass die nachfolgenden generationen in
meiner familie sich jeder auf seine
eigene art sehr intensiv mit der
geschichte immer beschäftigt hat und das
bis heute tut aber da gibt es ja ganz
viele unterschiedliche wege und mein weg
war es eben damit an die öffentlichkeit
zu gehen und das fanden auch nicht alle
gut
also erstmal ist das liga klingt jetzt
zum vorwurf als nestbeschmutzer ja
sicher dass es gibt es denke ich in all
diesen familien
also es ist generell denke ich so dass
in diesen sogenannten täter familien ist
in der regel eine person ist die s
übernimmt die geschichte aufzuarbeiten
manchmal hat man glück und man findet
noch ein paar unterstützer aber meistens
ist es nur einer der das macht und dann
gibt es eine ganz breite palette von
reaktion angefangen von denen die das
gut finden die einen zumindest passiv
unterstützen und uns sehr froh sind oder
erleichtert darüber dass man es gemacht
hat
die große schweigende mehrheit von dem
man nie weiß was sie eigentlich darüber
denken
von dem man es nie erfährt und dann gibt
es immer eine minderheit die ganz heftig
dagegen ist und die bitterböse ist weil
sie vermutlich selber große probleme
damit haben dieses bild was sie haben
von den vorfahren zu revidieren dass das
nur heinrich himmler der bösewicht war
und die anderen eigentlich ja eigentlich
weitgehend frei von schuld sind sie sind
ganz offensichtlich mit umgegangen
werden wahrscheinlich auch oft wegen
ihres nachnamens gefragt ob sie nicht so
oft gar nicht sie hätten auch nicht so
genau das wollte ich ändern
den namen da werde ich nie darauf
angesprochen eigentlich sie sind mit
einem juden verheiratet gewesen
gut der dessen familie schwer gelitten
hat wenn man gemeinsam das kind auch
dann sie auch mal gesagt dieses kind das
muss erfährt jetzt dass der eine teil
der familie also in form von heinrich
himmler oder heinrich himmler alles
daran gesetzt hat den anderen teil der
familie auszurotten wie sind sie denn in
ihrer familie mit ihrem mit diesem thema
umgegangen als ich das geschrieben habe
damals bei mein sohn natürlich noch
klein als ich diese angst hatte
inzwischen ist er 15 und natürlich weiß
er längst sehr gut bescheid über die
familiengeschichte sowohl der einen als
auch der anderen seite und ich denke er
geht erstaunlich gut damit um also ich
glaube tatsächlich dass er es recht gut
schafft in seiner generation so eine
eine art brückenkopf zu bilden zwischen
diesen beiden seiten also habe ich
zumindest das gefühl ich bin mir
natürlich nicht sicher aber es sieht so
aus und ich hoffe es für ihn dass das es
nicht schwierig wird für seine identität
sondern dass er weiterhin
so zwischen diesen beiden identitäten
hin und her switchen kann wir das bisher
tut das buchte sie geschieht mit den
titel erzähle es niemanden
das bezieht sich auf ein zitat ihrer
mutter ihnen gegenüber sie 18 jahre alt
waren hat in ihre mutter sozusagen das
familiengeheimnis dass das um diese
familie und das vorleben ihrer eltern
sich rankte geöffnet aber erzähle es
niemanden sie sollten es niemanden
erzählen das haben sie haben sich nicht
dran gehalten ganz im gegenteil sie
haben das jetzt jeden erzählt der es
wissen wollte oder vielleicht auch
wissen sollte dass sie war dass ihr
ausdrücklicher wunsch oder war dass ihre
entwicklung war das ihr bedürfnis diesen
ursprünglichen wunsch ihrer mutter zu
ignorieren zu sagen nein das muss man
erzählen mit dem einverständnis meiner
mutter dann natürlich aber es hat ja
lange gedauert
ich hab das erfahren da war ich 18 und
ich habe angefangen an dem buch oder
über das buch nachzudenken als ich mitte
50 war und angefangen zu schreiben habe
ich es dann nach dem mein vater
gestorben war weil meine mutter hat mein
vater zitiert erzähle es niemanden weil
mein vater überhaupt nicht darüber
sprechen wollte mein vater mit eben
nicht auch nicht mit mir also ich hab
sehr erfahren als ich 18 war da und kurz
davor war aus dem haus zu gehen nach dem
abitur und er hat meine mutter für sich
beschlossen ein dir an die muss wissen
welche wurzeln sie hat und sie hat mich
ins wohnzimmer geholt und da standen
dann drei tagen drei gegenstände auf den
tisch nämlich einen blechnapf ein
brustbeutel und eine armbinde
die armbänder aus dem
konzentrationslager theresienstadt
das war der der es nach meiner
großmutter in theresienstadt und auch
der brustbeutel auf dem in leder stand
gut und meine mutter hat gesagt dass und
das ist in deiner familie dein vater hat
ein jüdische mutter gehabt seine
großmutter war jüdin das und das ist
passiert aber papi möchte nicht dass du
erfährst weil er möchte nicht darüber
reden
aus vielen gründen und rhede bitte auch
nicht drüber erzählt sie
mein vater war damals sehr böse auf
meine mutter dass sie mir das erzählt
hat und ich habe dieses tabu sofort
verinnerlicht ich habe tatsächlich mein
vater
mein vater nie damit konfrontiert erst
viel viel später als ich dann doch
eigentlich von ihm wissen wollte was war
denn was ist denn und habe aber immer
gemerkt bei jedem kleinen versuch dass
er nicht wollte und er hat bis zuletzt
mit mir nicht darüber gesprochen
sie haben nichts richtig mit ihm
sprechen können vor seinem tod haben sie
eine erklärung dafür nie hat ihr das
gerät mutter den mut hatte ihr vater
aber nicht darüber zu reden
meine mutter war auch also sie sie
wollte erstens wie gesagt dass ich über
meine wurzeln bescheid weiß weil sie
denkt da hat ein mensch ein recht zu
über seine wurzeln bescheid zu wissen
sie wollte auch nicht dass ich von
irgendjemand anderem erfahre vielleicht
durch irgendwelche wege was in unserer
familie los war und meine eltern hätten
da nicht mit mir darüber gesprochen und
sie wollte auch der vielleicht dass ich
mich letztlich doch damit
auseinandersetze irgendwann mal und das
buch war natürlich der versuch
nachzuvollziehen warum mein vater nicht
darüber hat sprechen können wollen und
das ist mir gelungen durch das buch in
dem ich viele dinge recherchieren konnte
die ich nicht gewusst habe über die
ausbildung der studium meines vaters was
ihm passiert ist was ihm an grauenvollen
dingen passiert ist er war in
deutschland ein nicht ein bastard eine
missgeburt er in dieser zeit er hat so
viele erniedrigungen erlebt und wenn ein
mensch frau bode wird das natürlich noch
viel mehr wissen durch ihre gespräche
auch soviel demütigendes erlebt hat das
kennen wir alle aber auch wo man was
schlimmes erlebt hat da guckt man nicht
noch mal gerne hin und das zweite war
meine mutter hat natürlich nach dem
krieg auch erfahren in welcher
gesellschaft sie da eigentlich lebte
also sie hat mir hinter erzählt dass
meine eltern die waren in einem tanzclub
und da waren die mal die malerei umgeht
man hinterher nach hause und ostern
spargel und irgendwas und und dann
machte der ein oder andere juden witz
die runde oder irgendwelche unbedachten
bemerkungen fielen und meine mutter war
einmal das war so ende der 50er anfang
der 60er jahre sie zu meinem vater
gesagt jetzt rede ich drüber es reicht
es reicht mir mein vater witten im
ruhrgebiet zu der zeit hat gesagt nein
du redest nicht ich will keine
anerkennung und ich will kein mitleid
es war immer sein satz und er wollte zu
dieser bundesdeutschen gesellschaft
einfach wieder dazu gehören er wollte
nicht wieder ausgegrenzt werden
und er glaubte das kann dass dadurch
verhindern diese ausgehen sollten gehen
er verschweigt dass er halbjude ist
sollte ganz normaler bürger dieses
landes sein oder ein schweres
armutszeugnis für das land des wird es
zuletzt ja also ich meine ist jetzt auch
durch das buch erst klar geworden wie
viel in diesem land auch geschwiegen
wurde nicht geredet wurde sich nicht
auseinander gesetzt wurde so dass mein
vater für sich überhaupt nicht das
gefühl hatte ich bin ja auf sicherem
terrain ich bin hier ich werde gehört
werden
mir wird man jetzt anders begegnen ich
meine die waren doch überall noch an der
macht das wissen wir doch inzwischen die
alten nazis und das wusste er auch
erarbeitete dann wieder in der eisen und
stahlindustrie
da waren sie doch alle um ihn herum
versammelt sprich er hat auch ein preis
dafür gezahlt dass er nichts gesagt hat
sich das aus seiner sicht insofern
gelungen dass er dann doch das gefühl
hatte wieder dazuzugehören oder hat er
nie mehr das gefühl bekommen
zu diesem land zu gehören nach dem krieg
ich habe mit ihm gesprochen ich kann mir
vorstellen
tief im innersten ist er vermutlich
dieses gefühl der ausgrenzung nicht los
geworden er hat das versucht zu
überspielen mein vater war ein sehr
humorvoller mensch sein humor hat ihm
sicher geholfen sich so ein gerüst zu
bauen mit dem er psychisch klar gekommen
ist wurde dieses verhältnis zwischen den
kriegs enkel und ihren eltern in
kriegskindern unterschiedliche
erfahrungen möglicherweise auch
konflikte in der familie kann man
eigentlich erwarten dass das sehr viel
gegenseitiges verständnis da ist bei
diesen unterschiedlichen ergebnissen wie
haben sie das empfunden bei ihren
recherchen
man kann ja mal grundsätzlich sagen dass
die kriegskinder und die kriegs enkel
auf völlig unterschiedlichen planeten
aufgewachsen sind und es ist nicht nur
so dass die kriegskinder ihre kinder
nicht verstanden haben sondern auch die
kriegs enkel haben emotional lange zeit
nicht erfassen können was ihren eltern
als kinder widerfahren ist also ich
meine dass ein kind das mit fünf jahren
auf die flucht geht dass das ohne folgen
bleibt das wussten selbst menschen die
man fing mit 20 angefangen haben
psychologie studieren oder eine
psychotherapeutische ausbildung zu
machen
sie haben sich die fragen nicht gestellt
was bei dem mit meinen eltern
es sei denn sie kamen aus familien das
waren aber ausnahme familien sie haben
verstanden was ihnen passiert ist und
nein ich rede jetzt von der kindern an
die kinder haben weil die eltern immer
sagten entschuldigung die eltern sagten
ja immer alle haben überlebt und das ist
das wichtigste
und dann haben die deren kinder auch
nicht weiter überlegt mich leiter
gespürt so was ist ja das ist ja eine
starke solidarität was man als kind
seine eltern gegenüber hat und ich denke
das betrifft ja alle in der runde
man will ja die eltern stabil als kind
das ist das allerwichtigste
und man spürt ganz genau ohne worte das
kann alles nonverbal laufen dass man
diese eltern unruhig macht wenn man
bestimmte fragen stellt oder bestimmte
sachen beobachtet und dann das die
vielleicht nach macht sogar also kinder
merken ganz schnell wo die grenze ist wo
sie verwenden eltern wirklich
erschüttert sind und dieses und das ist
auch der grund warum lange bei den
kriegs enkeln das interesse an der
deutschen vergangenheit obwohl sie es ja
in der schule in einer fahrt von
überdosis eingetrichtert bekommen haben
die ausgesprochen gering es ganz anders
als bei der nachkriegs kindern und
amseln darüber ihren eltern gespürt die
auf ihre weise traumatisiert waren ihr
von ihrem vater haben sie erzählt ihre
mutter in norwegen ist in ihrer familie
dann auch durch diese liebe zu einem
deutschen wehrmachtssoldaten ja auch
angefeindet worden sie ist ganz
spektakulär nach dem krieg dann nach
deutschland geflüchtet zu ihrem späteren
mann wie haben sie die eltern in ihrer
erziehung in gegenüber zum beispiel da
empfunden hat man da irgendetwas gespürt
oder wie stabil sind sie ihn begleiten
vorgekommen so was von wo wir stehen wir
sehr stabil als kind hatte ich das
gefühl dass man stabile eltern
glückliche eltern
auch diese diese beziehung war ja eine
schöne geschichte eine schöne
liebesgeschichte die die immer so schön
erzählt wurde
und ich war nicht immer ganz stolz also
meine mutter norwegerin und ich war auch
immer ganz froh meine mutter als
norwegerin
das heißt wir gehören nicht zu den
tätern und da mein vater immer betont
hatte ich hab nur auf der schreibstube
gearbeitet mein vater zumindest nicht
geschossen mein vater hat niemanden
umgebracht das habe ich ihm auch schon
geglaubt und nachdem ich weiß mein
vorrangiges gefühl als ich dann erfahren
hatte dass mein vater aus einer
jüdischen familie da das dass das haupt
gefühl war
wir gehören insgesamt nicht zu den
tätern das war komplett erleichtert und
ich wollte noch zu ihnen seien frauen so
meine generation diese ein bisschen
dazwischen ist hat ja schon die eltern
so angegangen aber auf eine
konfrontative art und weise für wie
konntet ihr nur wieso habt ihr keinen
widerstand gemacht wieso habt ihr das
mit also dadurch kam es ja schon ganz so
gar kein gespräch weil die verletzungen
auch die so damit einher ging die
wollten wieder wollte meine generation
nicht zum thema machen
wir wollten anklagen und ich glaube es
ist ein riesenunterschied ob die eltern
kriegs erwachsenen oder kriegskinder
waren die kriegskinder die sind sehr
schnell instabil gewesen weil sie
innerlich einfach nicht gefestigt waren
den steckte das alles noch sehr stark in
den knochen
in der kita tiven system muss man sagen
ja und das haben deren kinder schon von
kleinauf gespielt ja ich glaube dass es
gibt es ist ja so viele kinder wie
möchten wie gesagt verboten
unsere werte und mutter stabil zusammen
aber es gibt auch eltern wie möchte dass
die kinder tragen
ich habe viele leser für mein buch die
das buch gekauft hat und gesagt hat ich
solle es um meine kinder geben so dass
sie vielleicht fragen sie könnte nicht
das direkt sagen aber ich glaube auch
mit meiner mutter sind möchtet
eigentlich dass sich fragte obwohl es
nicht leicht war so ich glaube es gibt
auch
von uns die das gespräch haben möchte
obwohl es nicht einfach ist
heute kann ihre mutter das buch lesen
teilweise jetzt lässt es sie in deutsch
aber es ja das manuskript so gelöst und
ein bisschen korrigieren
aber die ganze buch so können sie nicht
mehr weil ich aber meiner mutter die
erfahrung gemacht und ich hatte das
wunderbare dass meine mutter zu viel
aufgeschrieben hatte selber tagebuch
geführt hatte darauf konnte ich
zurückgreifen
aber ich habe in den jahren der als wir
zusammen gearbeitet haben an dem buch da
lagen ja diese tausend briefe die meine
eltern sich geschrieben hatte auf dem
esstisch und und sie ist immer weiter in
diese zeit zurück gegangen und da habe
ich erst gemerkt welche schmerz damit
verbunden war nämlich die demütigung die
sie in norwegen erfahren hatte
als freundin eines deutschen
wehrmachtssoldaten und sie hatte in
meinem vater das versprechen gegeben
darüber nicht niemandem etwas zu
erzählen da war wieder erzähle es
niemanden wenn meine mutter wollte sich
eigentlich trennen von diesem
wehrmachtsoldaten kurz nachdem sie sich
in ihn verliebt hatte weil sie dachte
das geht nicht ich kann nicht mit einem
besatzungssoldaten zusammen sein und
dann wurden auch die ersten juden in
hallstatt deportiert in nord norwegen wo
sie lebte und da hat sie ihn zur rede
gestellt und da hat er ihr sein
geheimnis erzählt und sie hat es für
sich behalten diese junge frau von
anfang zwanzig und die halbe familie hat
nicht mehr mit ihr gesprochen und das
kommt natürlich alles wieder hoch auch
bei diesen alten menschen jetzt und sie
ist noch genauso hat genau noch tränen
in den augen sofort also wenn bestimmte
namen bestimmte begebenheiten plötzlich
erzählt werden
sie geht kann auch nicht immer zu den
lesungen mit weil die das noch so auch
fühlt und das zeigt natürlich auch ja
nie darüber gesprochen mehr nie
verarbeitet wenn es überhaupt eine
paradox ich kenne so meine mutter sagen
sage was ich nicht hören möchte
und sie können sagen frage was ich nicht
erzählen möchte
aber man muss dann durch das gehen und
dann dann kommt man wieder im leben
ich würde gerne noch mal zurückkommen
auf die allgemeinen sachen die sie vor
gesagt haben frau wurde über die
kriegskinder generation und die gags
enkel
also ich denke dass es auch ganz wichtig
ist dabei mit zu denken dass die ja
nicht diese kriegskinder generation
nicht allein durch den schrecklichen
krieg geprägt sind
in all den auswirkungen die das dann
wieder auf die nächste generation hat
sondern dass sie natürlich auch durch
die nationalsozialistische erziehung
sehr stark geprägt waren die
allermeisten von ihnen
und das ist etwas was denke ich noch
viele viele jahre weiter gewirkt hat
weil auch diese unsäglichen erziehungs
bücher aus der nazi zeit noch den
nachkriegsjahren in riesigen auflagen
verlegt wurden und gelesen deutschland
in westdeutschland muss man dazusagen
dass zu diesen erziehungsmethoden
tatsächlich noch lange galten sozusagen
als norm eigentlich galten ja noch in
kombination dazu kam die wut über das
eigene verkorkste legen über die
schlimmen erfahrungen die man gemacht
hat die ängste die verdorbene jugend was
auch immer das dass dort besonders stark
dieses dieses gefühl erzeugt dass man
dass es eben solche probleme mit den mit
den kindern der der kriegskinder gab
dass die sich auch auf die erziehung der
eigenen kinder dann ausgewirkt hat das
sagen das ist auch dass diese erziehung
diese erziehungs vorgaben der nazis noch
so lange gewirkt haben aber gleichzeitig
man ja auch selbst als kriegsteilnehmer
als erwachsener als kind im krieg ja
schlimme dinge erlebt hat dass das
zusammengenommen eben es auch schwierig
macht hat seine eigenen kinder zb mit
liebe zu erziehen
das denke ich schon ich glaube dass es
einfach zwei unterschiedliche faktoren
sind die sehr starke auswirkungen haben
konnten darauf wie diese kriegskinder
generationen wiederum ihre eigenen
kinder erzogen hat das glaube ich schon
jetzt beides geprägten aus also es gibt
diesen satz den aus der enkelgeneration
und auch aus dem nachkriegs kinder
generation den ich oft gehört habe
die sagten ich glaube mein vater oder
meine mutter konnte uns nicht lieben
und das hat mit dem krieg zu tun also
deshalb sage ich dass krieg beschädigt
wirklich war vielen menschen nachhaltig
diese beziehungsfähigkeit und ich höre
es auch oft ja nach meinen lesungen beim
sanieren heißt es dann kommt eine frau
oder einen vater an und sagt zu können
ich konnte meine kinder auch nicht leben
also ich kenne das auch von vielen aus
dieser generation die als als kinder den
krieg erlebt haben und die nazi zeit die
von sich selber auch sagen im nachhinein
heute dass sie eltern waren die die
kinder gut versorgt haben aber dass sie
keinen emotionalen zugang zu ihren
kindern kriegen konnten und das ist
genau das was diese kinder auch häufig
so empfinden dass man über vor über
gefühle in der familie schlecht oder gar
nicht reden kann dass es sehr schwierig
ist von beiden seiten her also weil die
kinder natürlich auch immer gespürt
haben dass es dafür die eltern grenzen
gibt das ist das schwierig wird darüber
zu sprechen aber noch mal das bedürfnis
jetzt liegen wenn man so 50 60 ist wenn
die eigenen kinder groß sind wenn im
beruf schon so einiges geschafft ist
oder einige an der stelle zur
pensionierung stehen dazu noch mal so
eine klarheit zu schaffen in seinem
leben dazu eine haltung zu entwickeln in
seinem leben irgendwie ins reine zu
kommen mit sich in erster linie und mit
den eltern zu gucken was was ist dann
noch zu reden ich habe genauso wie sie
auf den lese und mache ich hätte es nie
für möglich gehalten was in diesem land
geschrieben worden
also es kommt so viel oder die briefe
die man bekommt oder auch die erfolge
unserer bücher zeige ja auch was für ein
bedürfnis und für ein vakuum da ist sich
mit dieser zeit noch mal zu beschäftigen
ich denke mein gott es ist jetzt 70
jahre her und das bedürfnis ist so da so
adcoach noch und so viele schmerzen sind
da und so vieles nicht verarbeitet aber
in vielen familien ist er bis zum
schluss geschwiegen worden und ab es zu
spät war darüber
möglicherweise wenn dann die jenigen die
kriegszeit gelebt haben gar nicht mehr
da war
jetzt finden die kinder die briefe auf
den dachböden oder kommen nämlich viel
sagen wir kommen auch in st ich habe
dann noch eine kiste ich weiß gar nicht
ob ich die öffnen können weil ich habe
angst dass ich damals lese was ich gerne
wissen möchte das ist so komplex und
wenn man liebe liebe sprach sprecher
meine mutter war beim ende die krieg
auch in einer busse bis dann so verliebt
und das war ja auch sehr gut dass sie
menge sehen könnte und auch russen sehen
können die gute menschen war dass das
ist in diese komplexe klicks über 30
jahre haben wir unsere vergangenheit
ziemlich weit gehend aufgabe also ich
will nicht sagen aufgearbeitet aber uns
damit beschäftigt und doch sehr weit
gekommen damit auch die ergebnisse sind
ja so dass wir an land sind dem mann
vertraut wir sind eingereiht in die in
die europäische union
man traut uns viel zuwider aber ich sag
mal ein aber bei dieser art von
aufarbeitung die war ich nenne das mal
akademisch ja wir haben das den
historikern und den polizisten
überlassen
und was seit einigen jahren begonnen hat
und dafür zeigt hier diese runde ist die
emotionale aufarbeitung und wo sollte
der ort dafür sein wenn ich in den
familien
das war ein gutes schlusswort ich
bedanke mich dass sie daran liebe
zwischen soweit die phoenix runde aus
anlass des 80 jahres taxis ende des
zweiten weltkriegs nur zuschauer bleiben
sie bei phoenix